the united nations nuclear watchdog is
calling for a security zone to be
established around ukraine's embattled
zapurujia nuclear power plant the iaea
says the current situation is quote
untenable this after a team of its
experts visited the site last week to
assess the damage and conditions for the
workers there since russian troops took
control of the facility early in the war
kiev and moscow have accused each other
of risking a radiation disaster by
shelling near the site
ndw's emmanuel shaz joins me from kiev
now emma good to see you the u.n is
gravely concerned about the state of the
plant what exactly did the report reveal
well this report
actually was expected here doesn't
really come as a surprise with the
international
atomic energy agency saying that the
situation is no longer
sustainable they've observed very grave
violations of the safety
on site and they warned that an incident
a nuclear incident could happen
any time due to military operations so
really an unsustainable
situation there they've also observed
something that had already been
actually warned against here by kiev is
the military presence of a russian
soldier so not only soldiers but also
equipment
ammunitions in a very sensitive zones
i'm thinking about
the the halls where the turbines
are located also they've observed some
damages to buildings where nuclear are
fresh nuclear fuel and also radioactive
waste is being stored
damages also
against a building where we find the
central alarm system of zaparija
power plants so many many violations of
securities of course they call
for a safety a security zone this zone
already existed prior to the war being a
nuclear power plant but repeatedly since
february 24th it has been violated by
the russian
occupants
there is concern about the plant of
course but also about the people who
live around it what's the situation like
for the people who
inhabit this area around the zabarija
plant
i would say i would say the primary
concern is for people who live nearby
and also in the region because we we
know that in case of a nuclear
catastrophe not just the immediate
vicinity will be affected but people who
are residents in the area you know most
of them there are families of people
working in the power plants they are
very very worried and also here in
ukraine people know the toll of a
nuclear
incident they had to
leave through the chernobyl incident in
the 80s it is very much present in
people's mind with many uh residents
leaving the area when they come when
they have haven't already done so but
also the international atomic
energy agency also saying that people
workers
workers in the power plant well they're
at risk as well directly to commit human
errors because of the amount of stress
they have to work under they're under
very high pressure they work under
constant observation of
the russian military troops there so
really a very
bloom situation there in sapporo emma i
want us to take a quick look at the
developments in other parts of ukraine
state with us and we'll talk more after
this report which starts in kharkiv in
the east
hit by rockets again and again
hakiv is ukraine's second largest city
its position in the east near the
russian border has made it a target
throughout the war
there was an explosion and our apartment
shook
pieces of tile hit my child's back and
the ceiling collapsed on my head
very thick smoke immediately filled the
room
we wanted to get out but our door was
blocked
it was blown into the corridor
hakeev's governor said rescuers are
still searching through the rubble for
survivors of the attack on this
apartment building in the city center
several people were killed in other
strikes in the region and air raid
sirens rang throughout ukraine on
tuesday morning
but in the country's south keeve says
it's successfully pushing back
ukrainian troops launched a
counter-offensive last week and say
they've already regained territory
this video appears to show soldiers
raising a ukrainian flag in a small town
in the hassan region that had been held
by russia since early on in the war
and our correspondent emmanuel is still
with us emma looks like that counter
offensive in the south is gaining
traction isn't it
exactly in fact the counteroffensive in
the south started early july so it's
nothing new what is new though is that
it has been a week or so that it has
made significant
gains in the south i would love to tell
you more about those games but the
situation being so critical
so sensitive there is no
regular updates as to which villages
exactly have been liberated as to where
exactly the army
is fighting against the russian
occupants so it's all a very very
sensitive topic here there are pictures
uh there are some videos on social media
despite the request of
the ukrainian army itself to not
talk about it on public media so as to
not give clues to the russian army about
what you know about the situation uh
despite that we can see some videos they
show destructions of ammunition they
post russian ammunition they post they
also
show a lot of
russian tanks russian equipment being
destroyed on the side of the road and
it looks like it's going well that is
gaining traction on the ukrainian side
with ukrainian president vladimir
zelesky even saying uh talking about the
liberation of two uh villages near her
son that finally ukrainian flags are
floating where they should be again and
perhaps the biggest giveaway that this
counter-offensive is going well for
ukraine is the fact that russia
has paused its prospects of wanting to
hold a referendum in occupied her son it
wanted to do the same as it did in
crimea in 2014 holding a referendum to
officialize the annexation of the region
it cannot do that at the moment because
of the counter-offensive a lot of
movement in ukraine emmanuel shah is
with the latest from there thank you so
much